welcome to another dr sadler's honest
reviews this is a series in which i'm
typically reviewing books in practical
philosophy in a very broad sense so
everything from philosophy itself and
ethics and self-help over to leadership
and what i'm going to be talking about
today
this book how animals grieved by barbara
j king is a bit of an outlier you might
say but i think there's a lot of really
great
lessons in here for thinking about our
humanity and our understanding of
animals and emotions and our connection
to them it is not that recent of a book
it's 2013
from university of chicago press but i
think that a lot of what it says in here
is
if not necessarily timeless certainly
timely
and i i wanted to review this book in
part because
i was reading it originally for a
project that i'm working on and then i
thought wow this is this is really quite
good
and it might be something that other
people could benefit from
and it does fit in with practical
philosophy again in a very broad sense
because it has to do with how we
understand ourselves and our emotions
and those of all the other
animals that we run across so
yeah i think it's it's well worth
checking out
i typically begin these reviews by
talking about three big s's that is
style
structure and summary and i'm actually
going to give a summary part first of
the work so it's it's a book about as
you could well imagine from the title
animals and
how they grieve and whether indeed they
do grieve in ways that we humans can
identify as such and understand and and
relate to
and it's focused very much on animal
behavior
and expression and what that tells us
about
emotions
so there's a lot of material here that
is being worked through
i'm going to give you more about that
when we get into the key ideas but the
overall summary
is that
many not necessarily all but many
animals do
in fact experience grief and this is
reflective
of something else that they experience
as well attachment and even
love you can't really grieve without
there being a loss and
a loss that you actually
register so that that is sort of the
overall summary i guess you could say
that another key part of the summary is
that barbara king
is bringing to bear all sorts of tools
and approaches
to help us understand this and to work
her way through this now as far as style
goes i found this book
very readable i think i think it's
actually very
well written
it
doesn't pander to a popular audience by
being
folksy when it doesn't have to be so
or saying oh shucks we're all in this
together or anything like that it's it's
quite nuanced it's quite
well thought out
and
while it's approaching things that are
coming from the sciences or from from
other disciplines
it is doing so in a way that i think the
ordinary reader
can
can get it and you know this is a
product of barbara king doing some
popular writing and presentation prior
to this so i think that definitely
shows in this it's very well researched
it's very well written and i think that
you know regardless of where you're
coming at
it should be a
pretty clear
volume
easy to make sense out of what she's
actually
saying even when she's sort of hedging
her bets
now as far as the structure goes i think
you know as many books
there's the table of contents kind of
reveals this it begins with a prologue
on grief and love where she's telling us
here's here's what i'm you know getting
at here's my methodology here's some of
my assumptions then there's a whole
bunch of we can call them thematic
chapters and i'll return to those in in
a moment
the book ends with an afterword and then
acknowledgements and readings and
resources and an index which is quite
nice but after the thematic chapters
that are oriented
around
particular animal
species or types of species
she approaches
several other
really key
elements and so one of these
is something that she introduced a
little bit earlier cross species
friendships and love and therefore
grief this is in chapter 10 called no
boundaries
and this is a topic about which we could
talk a lot i mean we exist now in an
internet age in which we can see youtube
videos of
cats playing with owls and cuddling up
with them
and also you know cats attacking
crocodiles to ward them off that's a
not a friendship but you know the cat is
doing that on behalf of the humans
perhaps or and and you know all sorts of
other kinds of friendships you know a
hippo with a rhino and we could go on
and on and on
um so that's that's a really important
topic there's a discussion of animal
suicide whether it really is suicide
whether it's intentional or not
there's
some discussions about humans as well uh
beginning in chapter 13
you know the difference between an
animal obituary and a human obituary and
whether it's okay to include them in the
same
newspaper page or website
there's an entire chapter called writing
grief which is examining things from the
human perspective
and then you know there's some it ends
essentially with a discussion of our
pre-human ancestors and whether they
really grieved or
not we know they at a certain point
rituals
burial rituals come into being
and we can think well what's what's
actually going on there and you know
they are closer to
the the other non-human animals than
than we are perhaps in certain respects
so
looking at animals might help illuminate
our own
origins
now the chapters that are there um
there's you know begins with one keening
for carson the cat so this is going to
be about cats
dog's best friend which also
includes other animals as well
and you know there's there's discussions
of
horses of rabbits and we could go on and
on with with the examples one that i
particularly liked was a chapter called
bird love which is about
corvids in particular the very highly
intelligent uh even tool using
quite complex language
using
birds that we encounter there's
discussions of elephants of monkeys
there's a chapter called sea of emotion
which brings together dolphins whales
and turtles and there's even a chapter a
little bit later on about bison death
this is where we get to the obituaries
right and there's discussions of of not
just monkeys but apes a lot of different
things
going on in here sheep pigs you know
lots of different types of animals being
discussed
so
that's probably enough about the three
s's at this point i would say
are some of the key ideas some of the
real takeaways from this work so
one that i think is really important to
highlight at the beginning
has to do with the kinds of claims that
are being
made about grief and about you know love
and associated emotions not all animals
of a particular species are going to
necessarily
grieve and
even if they do they won't necessarily
all grieve in the same way so she brings
up you know a
great example here
she says
just as every smart not every smart cat
is oscar not every dog mourns when
confronted with death we shouldn't fall
into the trap of making universality
a criterion for the existence of a
phenomenon by which i mean we shouldn't
require every dog to grieve in order to
believe that some dogs do almost
commonsensical but a lot of people leave
this out because there's there's a
tendency to think of animals as like
having a species being and their
instincts are revealed in that if they
don't all behave that way
and we can't explain the weird outliers
that it's not really part of their
makeup but you know it turns out that
animals are much more
um individuated and plastic than we
often have given them
credit for
another really key point i think that is
made well
in
the book
is that
you don't you don't have grief
without there being
a corresponding positive
relation or emotion that of love and
joy in the other and care
for the other when we see that animals
are grieving it's because they're
genuine genuinely is a
loss
and it's not just in all cases a matter
of habit it there's an attachment there
that can take on some pretty strong
manifestations so i think there's lots
and lots of great examples of that
in here and it happens in different ways
with different species so for example
she talks about these great herbivores
like the bison
and um elephants in particular
um being interested in the bones of the
deceased
and relating themselves to that whereas
you know with apes and monkeys they
might carry around the the corpse of a
dead child
um for a long time right and then
abandon it at a certain point or it
might be taken away from them
sometimes it's
not the
physical manifestation of the body
sometimes it's actually
where the death took place that the
animal will return to and
make sense of and relate itself to and
sometimes this leads to
the animal
that is grieving
you know
dying a few months later or a few weeks
later sometimes there are
new processes you know an animal for
example they've got example you know
cats that are grieving for another cat a
new kitten comes in and the new kitten
may be kind of a replacement but it
won't
it won't be related to in exactly the
same way as the beloved lost cat and
there's there may be a little reticence
whereas other animals will throw
themselves into
relationships with with other new
animals
another key idea
is that
it's possible to take reductive views
and oftentimes the sciences will will
promote these
of animal behavior and intentionality
and emotion and in this case grieving
but we don't have to be stuck there
there's no reason why we have to say oh
we have to be
totally scientific in a reductive way
about this and whatever is happening
with fluffy over there who's lost their
their mate their friend you know
whatever it may happen to be some other
animal we're just gonna assume that
they're a meat machine we don't have to
do that
um as a matter of fact that may be
in some respects
anti-scientific it may block the road to
genuine inquiry so that's a good point
that she's
making
another key thing that she says at one
point is that
we have to be careful in equating
expression with emotion it may be
quite possible
to
have an emotion
without that emotion being expressed
i mean we all have interior
lives do we not and this may be the case
for some animals as well and there's
also restrictions on how it is an
emotion
might be expressed depending on what
kind of animal we're thinking about you
know she doesn't discuss this in this
work but one of the things we know about
cats and dogs is that cats lack the
musculature that dogs have that allows
their faces to have a different kind of
expressiveness more similar to our own
than that of cats it doesn't mean that a
cat does not have the emotion of love
for example so
that's important
[Music]
i also think it's it's very interesting
that she does attend and not just in the
one single chapter but in a number of
chapters
to the existence of of cross species
relationships and friendships and again
i want to stress this point that one of
the things we have learned in recent
years is just how malleable
and open what we assume to be
instinctually driven
animals turn out to be how much learning
can take place how much
change and adaptability
and you know she points out that in some
cases animals may actually
seek out another that's not of their
kind rather than their own kind for the
friendship and the bond can be
quite strong one that would allow for
significant
grief
what are the particularly good points
about this work that recommend it to you
i've already pointed out that it's very
well written and researched and so that
may be a draw for some people but
one of the things that i found
most attractive and actually admiral
admirable about this work
is that barbara king
over and over again gives us
an excellent model for how to
speculate well
and what do i mean by this
she is telling us at a number of points
okay so
here's what the science tells us at
least the science as far as we know it
at this point which you know it's an
incomplete thing it's not a closed
system
here's the sort of things we observe
here's some things we might draw from it
i don't want to go so far as to say that
these speculations
must be true
or an adequate picture of things but
there's certainly something
to them
and so there's a kind of judiciousness
here that i i really like a
judiciousness about the
inferences and conclusions of others and
also about one's own as as the author
who's engaging in this and i think this
could be this could be a very useful
model for a lot of people
the book is extremely well organized
there's you know
references in later chapters to what has
been discussed in earlier chapters i
think that is uh in fact quite important
she tells you early on what framework
she's using
i mean this could have gone into the
summary part but i think it's it's kind
of good to bring this up she
says that
in the framework that i want to use
okay before that she says here's the
central idea when an animal feels love
for another she will go out of her way
to be near to positively interact with
the loved one for reasons that may
include but go beyond survival based
purposes such as foraging predator
defense mating and reproduction in the
framework i want to use this act of
choosing by one animal to be with
another is a necessary condition a basic
foundation for love but it is only a
necessary condition not a sufficient one
to claim that we've identified animal
love another ingredient is needed should
the animals no longer be able to spend
time together the death of one partner
being one possible reason
the animal who loves will suffer in some
visible way she may refuse to eat lose
weight become ill act out grow listless
or exhibit body language that conveys
sadness or depression and so this is you
know it's great to like clarify
at the beginning here's what i'm up to
here's what we're doing
in these these books
i i think there's a lot of
useful distinctions of different types
of situations
happening in this so i that's that's
another plus to this book for me as well
i think another thing that may be a
little
bittersweet but on the whole is a
positive
is that king
addresses
how we human beings
exhibit cruelty towards or indifference
towards animals and even exploit them in
sometimes horrific ways you know she
talks about the poaching
of
elephants for example and the damage
that that does to the
community of the elephants and to those
who lose their spouses
mates
uh
mothers you know
um
there's a lot going on there she she
also talks about
a few other things as well that i think
are quite important
one of the most
horrific of which is in the
one on animal suicide talking about the
bear bile farms
where
brown bears are confined
basically
their entire life
a black bear is rather sorry
each bear lies down permanently in a
coffin-shaped wire mesh crate for his
entire life years able to move only one
arm so he can reach out for food
without proper anesthetic drugged only
half unconscious the bear is tied down
by ropes and a metal catheter which
eventually rusts is stuck through the
abdomen into his gallbladder
horrific factory farming taking place
exploitation that that is is going on
she writes about dolphin killings
she also writes about um
here we go about
you know experiments on
various animals
she says i experienced an emotional
response of my own in reading about
these experiments
um i wish i had served on the animal
care committee that approved these these
tests there she's talking about
um voles but you know there's many
others think about you know monkeys that
are used in labs and all sorts of other
similar
things so she doesn't shy away from this
she actually gives something like what
we would call a trigger warning
when it comes to the bear
bile farms
and i i think that not looking away from
that sort of stuff and weaving it into
the narrative
i think there's there's an ethical
imperative that that answers to
so i think that's a good point of this
this work
that's probably enough about
good points
are there any things about the book that
i find problematic um
no not really as such uh i mean it's
it's not a completely recent book so
obviously we could say well there's
probably stuff that could be
incorporated into these perspectives
that would be you know changing the
picture
slightly or filling it in i mean the
book could be longer any book could be
longer and have more examples
these are the sort of nitpicking that
don't really get at the quality of the
work of course and and i could go on of
course as a philosopher i could say well
i wish she would have engaged philosophy
a little bit more
um deliberately and systematically but
it's a good book even if she doesn't do
that there's there's so much in here
already i could say well you know maybe
there's too many anecdotes and examples
in here but i actually i don't think
there are so frankly i don't have any
bad things to say about this book
other than those not really bad things
that i've already brought up
so my final thoughts if you're asking me
for a book recommendation i
unequivocally
endorse and recommend this book and say
that it's one that you should get and
and read
i myself came to this book
because i'm working on a longer term
project that has to do with
grief in part
about how to make
end-of-life
decisions
about one's own
pets which is an issue that's troubling
for many people causes a lot of anxiety
a lot of remorse a lot of second
guessing
and i thought that
reading this book might
not answer necessarily questions for me
but at least give me
more useful source material and it has
done that
i also think this is a great book
just on its own
if you want to engage in some some real
thinking about
what it is that the other animals that
we share the world with do in terms of
love and in terms of grieving this is
going to be
it's not answering every single question
but it's going to be a very
useful and interesting worthwhile book
for you to check out
you